A mergesort based on multi-way
merging has a memory transfer
complexity of n/L log
base of Z/L of n/ L.
So, is that good or bad?
As it happens, it's as good as we could
hope for, asymptotically speaking.
Let's see why.
You start with n items.
And for simplicity,
let's say that these items are unique.
Initially you haven't seen
any of the items yet.
So all you know is that there are n
factorial possible ways in which you
might order the data, right?
Yikes, that's a lot of orderings.
Of these orderings, the goal of sorting
is to find a specific one in which all
the items are in, for
example, ascending order.
>From this point of view, here's a sketch
of one way to determine a lower bound.
Suppose you read some
data from slow memory.
>From this data you learn something
which reduces the number of
possible orderings.
Now, let's be a teeny bit more precise.
Suppose there have been t-1 transfers.
Let K of t-1 denote the number of
possible orderings that remain.
And remember, initially,
there are n factorial such orderings.
Suppose that after you do t-1 reads,
you now do another read of block size
L from slow memory to fast memory.
If you've never seen these items before,
then there are L factorial ways
in which you can order them.
Now, if there are any other
items in fast memory already,
let's suppose that you already
know their relative ordering.
So, how many ways can you order up to
Z-L old items, plus the L new items?
It's at most Z choose
L times L factorial.
This is the factor by which the number
of possible orderings might go down.
Then after t reads,
here's the lower bound on
the number of possible orderings.
It's n factorial divided by Z choose
L times L factorial quantity to
the power t.
Now this count is actually a little
bit more conservative than necessary.
The L factorial assumes that we don't
know the order of the L items that we
just read.
But if you've read the L items
before then that won't be the case.
That's because you can only perform
n/L reads of items that have
never been read together before.
Thus we can refine this estimate
of the lower bound on K of t.
In particular L factorial to the t
becomes L factorial to the n/L.
We're almost done.
What you want to know now is when
does this right hand side equal one?
That is,
when does only one ordering remain?
The smallest value of t
such that this happens
is our lower bound on
the number of transfers.
That turns out to be what we were after.
n/L, log base Z/L of n/L.
To get this result,
you just need two common approximation
identities plus a little algebra.
I'll post a nice set
of notes by Lars Arga
that explains all this in detail
in case you're interested.
And you're definitely interested.
Because you love this stuff.
You love it.
[SOUND] That's you making
out with the stuff.
Shame on you!
This is a family course.